in the last five years the photography
of David yarrow has exploded on the
world stage his pictures of wild animals
in remote locations command hundreds of
thousands of dollars in part because he
makes so few available euros journey
from a kid with a camera selling prints
on the street - big-time banker and now
famous photographer has been fascinating
recently we were given access to his
latest i opening shoot and we talked
with him about his unusual path to
stardom that makes the magic resist i've
always believed that the best
photographers stand in front of the most
interesting things it's really that
simple from the Arctic to Africa to the
American West
David garrow's work shooting wildlife
indigenous communities and landscapes
has reshaped fine art photography you
never know when that big male is going
to come a combination of his extreme
planning and patience that's it right
recently in Southern California yarrow
only had a few minutes of perfect
sunlight to create his latest print a
staged shot on Sunset Boulevard
featuring one of the most famous models
in the world Alessandra Ambrosio a car
and a wolf here ambrosia wasn't
comfortable sitting next to the wolf
come on you're fine if you don't like it
we can shoot them independently yeah we
just do a composite of the two euro
improvised you've got to get that wolf
further forward in the car you have
Sunset Boulevard shut down people
honking at you like crazy a wolf for
wolves for walls he brings back ups just
in case the photo titled Chateau Marmont
was half of euros wolf of Wall Street
idea and homage to the Martin Scorsese
Leigh Nardo DiCaprio film we don't start
because our clients are already
answering the phone you all know this
scene early on
and the wolf of wallstreet he did one
picture outside and one inside a trading
room with Jordan Belfort the man the
wolf of Wall Street is based on euros
usual goal is to get as close as
possible to animals of all kinds that
includes traveling to South Africa with
British model Cara Delevingne to shoot
her in front of a lion you search David
Garrow on the internet this is one of
the first ones that comes up I mean
she's a British icon she is authentic
she is brave she's fearless she is
fearless Yarrow has also come face to
face with Black Panthers elephants
captured here with a special wide-angle
lens and tigers targets will kill you
Tigers the most vicious animals in the
world they will kill you for fun I'll go
in the cage I think and try and work
from the cage is there ever any fear
this fear of failure which is always
good but at fear of personal safety
never with animals with people yes I
mean my scary moments have always been
with people because people can buy weed
they can get drunk and make him buy guns
how animals can do those three things
one of euros most famous photos is a
kind of selfie with a polar bear where
if you look closely you can see his
silhouette in the Bears eyes I heard
somebody say once that most people
survive attacks with black bears or
Grizzlies but nobody's ever survived an
attack from a polar bear I think that's
probably probably true and yet you're
right there in its face well we do worse
than we do more than that because
they're very sweet tooth so you've
always got to be done you've gotta be
downwind from them never be upwind from
the polar bear because they wouldn't
smell you but if you're downwind and
then you cover yourself in chocolate but
we always say don't don't do it at home
David euro first became interested in
photography as a teenager snapping
pictures of sporting events in England
but following parental and economic
pressure he shifted to banking way back
in 1988 photography was something that
weird people did like they would be
trainspotters whereas banking is what
people do and now banking is what weird
people do and photography is what normal
people they're this amazing how far
we've come the arrow didn't get back to
photography full-time until 2012 by that
time his marriage had painfully fallen
apart I wasn't fond of myself my path to
redemption was to pick up my cameras and
go to the most remote parts of the world
that was the way that was my antidote
it's my personal pain euro has
cultivated an impressive list of
celebrity fans by now Tom Brady wrote
the foreword to his latest book when
people want to say something nasty about
me they'll turn right David yeah he's
he's taking some good pictures but you
know he's a businessman my mother was an
artist using much better artist than
mere sculptures and she she died
suddenly penniless because she thought
the commercial pursuit or the
monetization of her craft was shameless
I don't know let's be shameless let's
just that's we got it we've got a minute
that's how you feel about it when people
say that there's more interest in the
celebrity or that were the business part
of it than the actual art itself I think
you have to have a net market if people
want to if people want to turn around
and say yeah well or David a seed knows
the American football players and
British football players and supermodel
or whatever I work with them I think
you've done a remarkable job hero can
take months to plan one picture but once
everything is in place things move fast
from Sunset Boulevard to here yeah and
we pride ourselves on our work I think
we shot this twenty six hours ago and
here is the final version he then only
releases a limited number of original
sign pictures single prints can go for
well over $100,000 do you ever stop to
think about that that you're producing
pictures that they demand that amount of
money in 1985 I photograph Wimbledon I
go home I would print up my pictures in
the darkroom and I would sell them on
the streets the next day for 20 quid a
picture
so when you go from silly pictures on
the street for 20 quid to seeing one of
your pictures guess other bits of course
you think about the fact that your
journey is as worked and your hard works
paid off so that garnish do I go to bed
thinking about it no I just want to get
better
son of a genius strategy right you only
release a certain number and then never
print those photos again so only a
certain number stay in circulation and
that's why they're so valuable